- I love that you sing
a song before, you know,
like you were saying, you
sing before you go out.
Why did you choose the song that you sing
before you go out on SNL?
And like, is there,
did that tradition start
with you doing that?
Or were you asked to do that?
- No, I graduated into it.
It was a thing, I think
like when I first got there
Jimmy Fallon was doing it
and he was like rocking out or something.
Like he was a rockstar.
So he was playing the
guitar and doing a song.
And then Fred, when I
first started doing it
I started doing it with Fred
and he was playing the guitar
and I was playing like
the Congas or something.
And it was me, him and Taran
Killam and we were singing
you know, a song from the
Clash, I want to say, but yeah,
just whoever's the
responsibility is you get to
choose whatever song you like.
So Fred, you know, he's
a guitarist and, you know
he was in a band for real.
So he was in like the rock
and roll kind of genre.
And then when he left,
they were like, well,
who's going to do the warmup?
And I was like, yeah, I'll do it.
And I started with like an obvious one
like Elton John Saturday,
you know what I mean?
So I sang that for
awhile and that was fun.
And then I moved into like, Oh,
let me start feeling my groove.
And I started doing
like the Doobie Brothers
Long Train Running and stuff like that.
And now we landed on
the Spencer Davis group,
Give Me Some Loving,
which is like just a solid
crowd pleaser basically.
And everybody seems to like it.
It gets the energy going and we've been
on that for like eight years
or something like that.
So it's been a minute.